a 44 billion dollar deal to buy twitter
is now off the table the richest man in
the world elon musk says he's
terminating the contract three months
after locking in the agreement
he accuses the company of failing to
provide information about fake accounts
on the platform and whether they make up
fewer than five percent of users
twitter's board chair says it kept its
end of the contract and is planning to
sue i think twitter probably would
prevail in this i would think simply
because there is a deal now musk can get
out by paying a billion dollar fine or a
billion dollars but it's not really a
fine a billion dollar penalty and my
guess is that that's what he's trying to
prevent is not having to make that
billion dollar payment
for many the focus now turns to stocks
and whether twitter and tesla will take
a hit
i think investors want to see must just
get back to focusing on tesla spacex
because twitter from the beginning has
just really been a distraction it's been
overhanging the stock
musk's bid to take over twitter steered
controversy back in april critics were
concerned the tesla ceo would promote
misinformation on the popular social
media site especially on matters related
to politics and health
musk said the acquisition was about
stopping censorship and defending
freedom of speech analysts say the
billionaire may have experienced buyer's
remorse he's trying to walk away and the
way these contracts are structured it's
very difficult for buyers to walk away
they're they're these contracts are
drafted with a hot to to provide a high
degree of certainty for the sellers
now terminating the 44 billion dollar
contract will have to play out on the
legal front and social media will surely
have plenty to say about it
katie lopez
al jazeera